اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مدينه القدس اهلا
بكم 20 شهيدا
و150 مصابا في قصف اسرائيلي لفلسطينيين
ينتظرون تسلم مساعدات في مدينه غزه واكثر
من 50 شهيدا ووم جريح في قصف لمدرسه تؤوي
نازحين واطلاق نار من مسيرات على معسكر في
خان يونس في هذه الاثناء قال الهلال
الاحمر ان ان الاحتلال يواصل استهداف
مستشفى الامل في خان يونس لليوم الرابع
ويمنع حركه
الاسعاف الجزيره تحصل على صور تظهر تفخيخ
الجنود الاسرائيليين منازل في غزه قبل
مقتل اكثر من 20 منهم مصدر قيادي في
القسام يقول ان مقاتلي الكتائب رصدوا
القوه الاسرائيليه الهندسيه قبل استهدافها
والمقاومه تطلق دفعه صواريخ من شمالي
القطاع باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه وفي خان
يونس قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي عنيف واشتباكات
في مناطق وسط وغرب المدينه وكتائب القسام
تقول انها استهدفت دبابتين اسرائيليتين من
نوع ميركافا
كاميرون يؤكد للجزيره ضروره وقف اطلاق نار
انساني فوري في غزه يفضي في النهايه الى
وقف دائم ووسط خلافات داخليه وزير في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يحمل نتنياهو مسؤوليه
الاخفاق في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر وعشيه
نطق محكمه العدل الدوليه بالحكم بشان
التدابير المؤقته في قضيه ارتكاب اسرائيل
جرائم اباده جماعيه فريق من مئات المحامين
يقدمون ادله جديده للمحكمه
الدوليه وسط تصعيد اسرائيلي متواصلا في
الضفه الغربيه استشهاد فلسطيني برصاص
الاحتلال خلال اقتحامه مدينه جنين وجيش
الاحتلال يقتحم ساحه المهدي في بيت لحم
ومدينتي رام الله ونابلس وينفذ عمليات
اقتحام في الخليل ويدهم منازل في مخيم
الفوار الى
اللقاء